astronauts for that announcement now I'm
here with Joseph eros from Hayes light
Joseph you were at the first game awards
back 2014 announced him something named
codename haze light now we know it's a
way out it's coming out next year so how
does it feel to be back at the game or
where it's four years later look at me
man how do I look it's like I'm telling
you this okay there are eggs there are
like passionate people they're crazy
people and there is me I'm so passionate
to be here I'm so excited to be and
meeting this industry it's insane like
we're here we're services look the
Oscars should [ __ ] themselves up this is
the [ __ ]
I'm telling you this is this is the real
[ __ ] let me give me a minute I want that
your time look ok can you swear here
kiss okay [ __ ] Oscars you know
here's the thing the gaming industry
it's an interactive is usually a lot of
films and now you're in games yeah
that's right you know I've done six
features about yeah but okay we're here
to talk about our way out let's - yeah
let's get into your game Joseph a way
out
co-op game you showed it at e3 yeah
excited about it or you get a new clip
of it tonight what can you tell us about
what we're gonna see tonight what can I
tell you yeah my friend I'm telling you
yes alright this is why I can tell you
look this is insane if if the whole
world tell me your game is [ __ ] I'll
tell them no it's not that's how much I
believe in it okay all right I'm telling
you like if you play the game from the
beginning to the end and you see what it
is it's impossible you don't like it
okay
impossible make sure to play with a
friend that's not a run-and-gun place
for you and your friend can play with
this is the thing yeah and this is my
idea it doesn't have anything with the
EH [ __ ] coming off the loot box and
stuff okay now look I'm gonna say to you
one thing and they say it's you're
wanting he has been very good to me and
and that to be honest with you they're
getting because it's nice to Haiti a
blah blah I don't care about that [ __ ]
what I'm saying is this all publishers
[ __ ] up sometimes you know that's how it
is they [ __ ] up but that's what it is
like in this case it's like they've been
treating me very well that's what I'm
saying this means I have a hundred
percent of the income to my team for the
game I'm doing you know it's Commission
right yeah it's gone I'm talking too
long that's okay it's like we got a long
show Jose be fair to everybody
is my time to shine man well your games
coming out well shut down sedate which
[Music]
we can before we talk today so we are
something that is we call it the France
but it's my idea from the get from the
first I'm a passionate man nobody would
ever even if I do triple a the
independent game but even if I do that
it will always be the game I want it to
be all right come to the point soon a
way out we gotta go here we go our way
out coming out next year check it out
Joseph Farah he's a fashion again
[Applause]
right there
right
a way out is a cinematic story-driven
co-op game or unit friend control
Vincent and Leo together whether on a
couch or online you'll get to know these
characters Leo is brash cocky and quick
to use force how about this while
Vincent is calm cool and in control
lapel you don't want to do something
you'll regret
Vincent and Leos personalities are
reflected in the way they interact with
the surroundings my seeing double who
are you two twins we're twins figures a
way outs linear story will take human a
friend through a cinematic experience
unlike any other co-op let's go through
the story you'll find yourself working
together to survive hey let's eat
reconnecting with loved ones she's so
beautiful for high stakes moments like
robbing a gas station you ready yeah why
don't you get me the gun I say we do
this the fast way man just in an hour I
say we do this the easy way let's not
make a scene
nobody moves stay calm
nice didn't know you had it in you what
can I say I'm full of surprises and
mostly good ones okay now you're getting
cocky
[Applause]